[موسيقى]
أداء كولد بلاي جنة تحت سماء
مليئة بالنجوم
[موسيقى]
أداء حميمي لكنه قوي
تحت قبة الوصل المتلألئة في
معرض إكسبو 2020 في دبي ،
كان هذا أول حفل موسيقي لهم منذ
بداية الوباء
وللمعجبين المحظوظين الذين تمكنوا من ذلك  الحصول على تذاكر
قد يسميها البعض بالسحر
[موسيقى
] أعرف أن الكثير منكم قد جاء من
مسافة طويلة وقد سافر الكثير منكم
إلى الداخل وأعلم أن الكثير منكم قد
خضع لاختبارات المرور والطمع
وارتداء الأقنعة و  كل الأشياء التي يجب
أن تمر بها هذه الأيام من بعض النواحي
تبدو وكأنها بداية فصل جديد ،
لذا
أشكرك على وجودك هنا ،
كيف تشعر بأداء مباشر مرة
أخرى وكيف أثر الوباء عليك
كفنان و
أعتقد أنه عندما ترى كلبًا
كان يعرج قليلاً ،
يتم إطلاق سراحه في الحديقة مرة أخرى ، هذا
ما نشعر به بالنسبة لنا تمامًا ،
لقد عدنا
وبامتنان أكثر قليلاً من أي وقت
مضى  أعتقد أن الجميع
أي شخص أنا  يشعر أي نوع من أنواع الترفيه
بمزيد من الامتنان
للتفاعل مع الناس لأننا
لم نأخذها أبدًا قبل أن أعني أنني
أحب كل جمهورنا في كل
مكان ، لكن هذا كان هناك
بالضبط قالت الفرقة الحائزة على جائزة جرامي سبع مرات
لقد توقفوا عن القيام
بجولاتهم في عام 2019 حيث عملوا على كيفية
جعل حفلاتهم الموسيقية أكثر صداقة
للبيئة وكان تركيزهم على الاستدامة هو
ما لفت انتباه منظمي إكسبو 2020 ،
حيث يقوم كولدبلاي بالعديد من الأشياء
الجيدة للبيئة ولأجل  الكوكب
وهذا ما حاولنا القيام به في إكسبو هو
حقًا تصميم جميع برامجنا حول
الأشخاص والكواكب وهذا هو السبب وراء
قدوم 192 دولة إلى هنا والقبة
التي تمثل إحساسًا
بالشمولية وتجمع الجميع معًا
كما تعلمون هناك  هي مؤتمرات
حول العالم لا تقرأ
عنها حيث يتجمع الناس وينظرون إلى
تكنولوجيا الأسلحة الجديدة والصواريخ
الجديدة والطرق الجديدة لقتل وإيذاء الناس ،
لذا فإن هذا  إنها جميلة على عكس ذلك
حيث توجد كل هذه الأجنحة التي
تخبرنا كيف يمكن للعالم أن يكون أفضل
وأكثر لطفًا وأنظف وأكثر اخضرارًا
معًا وهذا رائع حقًا
لذلك نحن فخورون بوجودنا هنا الآن
نحن جالسون تحت أكبر
لوحة شمسية  الشيء الذي رأيته من قبل إنه
رائع
هو أن كل هذه الطاقة القادمة من كل هذا
المبنى يتم تشغيلها بواسطة هذا الشيء الموجود فوق
اليمين ، وكل الماء في هذا
المبنى يأتي من الغلاف الجوي
أيضًا وأي شيء إضافي يذهب إلى
الشبكة ، نعم
لا تفعل ذلك  لا أريد أن أستمر
[ضحك]
العام الماضي ، أصبحت الإمارات العربية المتحدة أول
دولة في منطقة الخليج تلتزم
بصافي انبعاثات كربونية صفرية بحلول عام 2050
تقريبًا في نفس الوقت الذي تعهدت فيه كولدبلاي
بالحفاظ على
موسيقى الجولات العالمية القادمة في المجالات على أنها
مستدامة  وانخفاض الكربون قدر الإمكان ،
مما يؤدي إلى خفض انبعاثات ثاني أكسيد الكربون بمقدار النصف
مقارنة بالجولات السابقة ،
أخبرنا عن موسيقى الكرات
التي تبدأ في غضون أسابيع قليلة في كوستاريكا ، حيث
نجرب بعض الأشياء الجديدة مع
كيفية  برنامج e show مدعوم
وكيف يمكن للأشخاص
[الموسيقى]
كيف يمكننا القيام بأشياء معينة
بأموال تذاكر الأشخاص
ولا أريد التحدث
عنها كثيرًا قبل ذلك لأنه إذا
لم ينجح ، فسأفعل  أشعر بالسوء حقًا
ولكننا نحاول
أن يكون العرض بأكمله مدعومًا من
الوقود المتجدد المستدام بدلاً من البطاريات
والطاقة الشمسية
وزيت الطهي
والأشياء التي تعمل بالطاقة ، وهناك أجزاء من
الأرضيات التي تولد الطاقة من خلال
القفز على الأرضيات الحركية إذا كنت تحب
أغاني كولد بلاي
وأنت  مثل القفز صعودًا وهبوطًا ، اذهب إلى
كوستاريكا ،
نعم ستقضي وقتًا ممتعًا